we've also had a statement in the last  few moments from mr zelinski's office  outlining what was said uh and this is  what uh the reaction was so president  zelensky's saying we all heard this news  with sadness not only me but also the  entire ukrainian society which is very  sympathetic to you my entire office and  all ukrainians are grateful to you for  your help  goes on to say we have no doubt that  great britain's support will be  preserved but your personal leadership  and charisma made it special so the  words there from the ukrainian president  uh vladimir zielenski a very warm  language there from the ukrainian  president and it's no secret really that  is a man who believed that boris johnson  has been instrumental  in pushing the support both  diplomatically and weapons-wise to  ukraine